Ich glaube, das ist ein ganz wichtiges Kriterium, dass die Spieler untereinander sich pushen, sie einfach eine Stimmung entwickeln, wo man sich wohlfühlt in dieser Mannschaft. Wenn ich morgens in die Kabine komme, die man so im Gesicht habe, dann wird es schwierig. Ich glaube, da ist jeder gefordert, vor allem die älteren Spieler als Vorbildfunktion. Und vor allem der Trainer, logischerweise.
Er ist ein ganz, ganz großer Trainer. Wir werden alle erst in den nächsten Jahren, wenn es irgendwann mal wirklich besprochen wird, wann ging das los mit Ballorientierung, verhalten werden, werden wir feststellen, dass Wolfgang einfach – ich weiß nicht, ob er der erste war, aber er war einer der allerersten. Und oft ist es so, wenn Großes passiert, bekommen wir den Lohn dafür erst zu spät. Und wir profitieren alle davon. Er ist ein außergewöhnlicher Mensch gewesen und wir werden ihn alles vermissen.
Die längste Winterpause der Bundesliga-Geschichte.
Ja, genau. Und da beschweren sich einige über die Winterpause in diesem Jahr. Es ist ja ein Klacks dagegen.
Ja, vielleicht noch kurz was hinzufügen zu dürfen. Ich glaube, Rot-Weiß-Essen ist ja auch eine Entwicklung, die er ja dann vollzogen hat. Vielleicht auch mit noch einer größeren Überzeugung, dann wirklich seine Idee des Fußballs umzusetzen. Ich glaube, Essen war damals, wie gesagt, in einer schwierigen Situation. Er musste das Pokal-Halbfinale gegen TV Berlin unbedingt gewinnen. Jürgen Röber ist kurz vorher nach Stuttgart, glaube ich, gegangen. Das war ja auch ein wegweisendes Spiel, dieses Halbfinale, um gerade finanzieller Natur das Finale zu erreichen. Ich weiß noch, wie wir damals in der Schweiz saßen und uns das Spiel anguckt haben. Ich glaube, es gab kein Spiel, wo ich so nervös war, weil wir wussten, was da dran hängt. Auch der Verein ist quasi zwangsabgestiegen. Du musst aber das Pokalfinale irgendwie erreichen, damit der Verein noch eine Zukunft hat, weil da auch viel Geld dran hängt. Ich glaube, auch nachher hat er so angefangen, wirklich zu sagen, okay, jetzt auch aus der Situation vielleicht zu lernen, von Rot-Weiß-Essen, zu sagen, okay, in Mainz, ich bin absolut Verfechter dieser Idee und ich werde die jetzt versuchen, umzusetzen. Ich glaube, das ist ja auch so eine Transformation gewesen. Auch er, der versucht hat, dauernd eine eigene Entwicklung voranzutreiben, war das wahrscheinlich auch so ein Punkt. Dann von Essen zu Mainz, dann doch zu sagen, ich muss jetzt komplett all in gehen mit meinen Ideen, um dann auch erfolgreich zu sein und nicht jetzt irgendwie diese großen Kompromisse einzugehen, die er vielleicht teilweise doch noch vorher gemacht hat. Wie Mara schon sagte, war auch in der Wintertour Jogi Löw sein Spieler. Ich war da auch Jugendspieler in der Wintertour und habe das dann, nachdem er entlassen wurde, auch ein bisschen mitbekommen. Das war eine seltsame Stimmung, wo er mit Jogi nicht so richtig konnte. Und das war witzig, weil ich dann…
Und er war Kapitän. Genau.
Und auch im Nachgang, muss ich sagen, war es trotzdem auch von Jogi Löw. Den habe ich ein paar Jahre später mit meinem Opa dann beim VfB Stuttgart getroffen. Wir waren im Urlaub bei meinem Opa und sind dann regelmäßig zum VfB gefahren. Und dann kam Jogi Löw als Co-Trainer von Rolf Fringe auf mich zu und sagte, ach du bist ja der Sebastian. War total offen und freundlich. In Winterthur hast du gemerkt, die Stimmung war so ein bisschen getrübt. Aber auch Jogi Löw hat da ja auch wieder einen ganz anderen Blick auf einmal als Trainer darauf bekommen. Er war Spieler, war auch schon ein bisschen älter, hatte ein gewisses Standing in Winterthur. Und da war es ja auch schwierig, immer so Veränderungen herbeizuführen, weil natürlich die Offenheit und Bereitschaft nicht da war. Und ich glaube, auch bei ihm, bei Jogi ging es dann ja später auch los, als Trainer ganz anders die Dinge zu sehen, was ja Mara auch im Buch gut beschreibt, auch mit dem Gespräch mit Jogi Löw. Und ich glaube, das war bei unserem Vater auch immer so. Es war ein steter Prozess, der dann halt im Mainz am Schluss in der Viererkette geendet ist.
Ich muss auch sagen, das Gespräch mit Jogi Löw war eins, was mich echt auch sehr nachhaltig beeindruckt hat. Also ich würde ungern irgendwie Gespräche hervorheben im Sinne von, das war jetzt irgendwie besonders toll oder besonders wertvoll oder so. Das waren sie sicherlich alle. Trotzdem ist es ja so, dass man mit Leuten spricht für so ein Projekt, von dem man vorher selber vielleicht noch nicht so furchtbar viel gehört hat und natürlich eben auch mit Leuten spricht, die einem selber im täglichen Fußballumfeld immer schon sehr präsent waren. Und zuletzt zählt Jogi Löw logischerweise. Und ich war mir auch gar nicht sicher, ob er überhaupt Lust hätte, weil es eben nicht so sehr lange nach der Beendigung seiner Zeit als Nationaltrainer war, halt schon so ein längeres Gespräch zu führen. Aber es war relativ schnell klar, dass er gesagt hat, wenn es eben um Wolfgang Frank geht, dann macht er das. Und es war ja wirklich so, dass letztlich Jogi Löw auch nicht ganz unbeteiligt daran war, dass die Zeit von Wolfgang Frank in Winterthur dann eben nicht länger gegangen ist, weil es letztlich fast so ein bisschen einen Machtkampf zwischen den beiden gab. Und er hat da aber in einer total großen Offenheit drüber gesprochen und auch wahnsinnig reflektiert. Und genau mit den Punkten, die Basti gerade auch schon angesprochen hat, dass er eben gesagt hat, er hat eigentlich Wolfgang Frank und das, was er von Wolfgang Frank vielleicht auch noch hätte mitnehmen können, erst begriffen, als er selber Trainer geworden ist. Weil er damals als Spieler und auch als ein Spieler, der einerseits schon zu den Älteren gehörte, andererseits aber im Verein eben auch noch relativ neu war, da nicht so in der Lage war, das anzunehmen. Und letztlich, sagt er aber, gehört Wolfgang Frank für ihn auch zu den Trainern, von denen er total viel mitgenommen hat. Und er hat auch eine Szene erzählt, wie er später, als er Frank mal als Trainer wieder getroffen hat, also als dann Jogi Löw eben selber auch schon Trainer war, zu ihm hingegangen ist und ihm eben gesagt hat, dass es ihm im Prinzip leid tut, dass er das aus heutiger Sicht anders machen würde als Kapitän in dieser Rolle. Und dass Frank damit aber dann auch gut umgegangen ist. Also es fand ich schon von jemandem in seiner, ich sag mal, Position schon auch wirklich toll, wie offen und wie reflektiert er mit dem Thema umgegangen ist. Und man hat auch fast so ein bisschen, oder ich hatte auch fast so ein bisschen das Gefühl, es war ihm ein Bedürfnis dazu nochmal was zu sagen, weil das bei ihm echt hängen geblieben ist, dass er eben das Gefühl hat, er hätte damit anders umgehen sollen.
Und er ist auch nicht der einzige heute große Trainer, der mit Wolfgang Frank aneinandergeraten ist. Vielleicht liegt das ja auch an der Art und Weise, wie Wolfgang Frank eben seine Rolle und aber auch die der Spieler verstanden hat. Ihr habt das beide vorhin schonmal angedeutet, aber ich glaube, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, um das nochmal herauszuarbeiten. Also das war eben nicht einmal anderthalb Stunden Training am Tag und dann sehen wir uns morgen wieder, sondern das waren durchgeplante Tage. Das ging morgens los. Bei vielen Stationen gab es auch geplante Mittagsruhen, die am Trainingsgelände vollzogen wurden. Er hatte später mal bei einer seiner Stationen die 24 Stunden am Tag eingeteilt, hat gesagt, acht Stunden Schlaf, acht Stunden arbeitet ihr mit mir und acht Stunden habt ihr dann Freizeit, während er dann wahrscheinlich noch weiter gearbeitet hat, um den nächsten Tag vorzubereiten. Also Sebastian, das war ja auch schon sehr, sehr fordernd. Und unter anderem beim FC Winterthur war es so, da gab es manchmal drei Trainings am Wochenende. Plus dazu noch die Spielersitzungen, in denen er eben taktische Dinge erklärt hat, die eben nicht besonders kurz waren. Wir haben vorhin schon mal angesprochen. Und dass, obwohl manche der Spieler damals noch unter der Woche gearbeitet haben, also sehr, sehr viel fordern von den Spielern, dadurch auch viel fördern. Wie ist denn da die Grenze deiner Meinung nach? Und wie hat sich da auch dein Vater dann herangetastet? Denn du hast es ja, so wie ich es jetzt vorhin herausgehört habe, durchaus auch manchmal auch am eigenen Leib erlebt, wenn er dir eben eigene Trainingspläne, sage ich jetzt mal, geschickt hat. Wie blickst du jetzt auf diesen Aspekt der Trainerarbeit von deinem Vater?
Ich glaube, das fing ja auch schon alles in Klarus an, wo er anfing als Trainer. Da waren ja alle berufstätig. Und trotzdem hat er ja dann… Und ich glaube, das war auch die Basis seines Denkens, glaube ich schon auch. Ich muss sagen, von der Erzählung alleine her, von meinem Opa, von ihm, weiß ich ja schon, wie viel er wirklich investiert hat in seine Spielerkarriere. Ich glaube, das ist ja schon die Anfänge. Das waren ja dann so ganz lapidare Dinge wie Schwimmbad, Besuch und andere Sachen. Erstens hatten sie wenig Geld als Familie. Und zweitens war aber auch so, da war Fußball, da war alles. Also, da war jeden Tag Trainieren. Das war dann auch, wo er uns jeden Tag gesagt hat, zu, ihr müsst immer trainieren, ihr müsst mehr machen als jeder andere, sonst wird das nichts. Ihr müsst hungrig sein. Und diese Gier und diese Mentalität hat er schon versucht zu vermitteln, als uns, als Kinder. Und hat dann auch immer berichtet, wie er damals das gemacht hat, wie oft er irgendwie alleine gegen das Garagentor geschossen hat. Und ich glaube, das ist so die Basis. Und später auch in Klarus, da gab es Dachdecker, die haben zehn Stunden bei Bullenhitze auf dem Dach gestanden. Und trotzdem sind sie abends ins Training gegangen. Und er hat ihnen maximal das Abgefordert. Und ich glaube, das sind schon so diese Kernelemente, die er dann ja auch später noch weiter ausgebaut hat. Dass er dann überlegt hat, okay, wir müssen mehr tun, weil wir vielleicht individuell schlechter sind. Heißt, wir müssen mehr Aufwand betreiben als die Mannschaften, die besser sind. Und er hat das versucht zu kompensieren, indem er dann anfing, auch mit gemeinschaftlichem Frühstück und dann Trainingseinheit und dann Mittagessen und dann Ruhe und dann Wiedertraining. Und auch die Trainingslager waren ja auch so strukturiert. Er war ja dann auch gerne mal drei, vier Wochen irgendwo im Trainingslager, weil er dann alle beisammen hatte. Und aber auch, ich glaube, nicht nur den Ansatz von mehr Training, sondern auch dieses Gemeinschaftsgefühl zu stärken, dass man auch eine Gruppe – ich glaube, das ist ja auch so eine Dynamik als Fußballlehrer – zu gucken, wie kriege ich eine geschlossene Gruppe hin, die bereit ist, für sich einzustehen und alles Mögliche zu tun. Und wenn individuell die Qualität nicht so hoch ist, müssen wir das irgendwie anders kompensieren. Und ich glaube, das sind alles so Punkte, die bei ihm eine große Rolle gespielt haben. Und er versucht hat, bei allem noch ein paar Prozent rauszukitzeln. Und das war ja bei allen Stationen dann so. Ich glaube, erst später wurde er so ein bisschen lockerer in seiner Art, dass er auch mal eine andere Sichtweise akzeptieren konnte. Lange war es halt schwierig. Sobald man nicht der gleichen Meinung war oder auch Spiele mal gesagt haben, zu Trainer, das ist zu viel oder wir müssen da ein bisschen runterfahren, war er ja tendenziell auch schon schnell beleidigt. Und hat es dann auch so als persönlichen Angriff gesehen, dass seine Herangehensweise so kritisiert wird. Das war auch immer so ein heikles Thema mit ihm. Wenn irgendwas nicht so war, wie er es wollte, war es teilweise schwierig mit ihm zu reden, weil er einfach total überzeugt war, dass mehr besser ist. Und das hat er auf allen Stationen fast so gehalten. Ich glaube, diese Balance hinzukriegen, das hat ihm manchmal so ein bisschen gefehlt. Dennoch glaube ich, haben da auch gerade jetzt viele Spieler in dem Bereich, in dem er trainiert hat, schon auch extrem von profitiert, das erste Mal zu erleben, was das heißt, professionell seinen Beruf nachzugehen. Weil, verglichen mit anderen Sparten, ist es natürlich teilweise was, der gesagt hat, wie wollen wir das rechtfertigen, wir machen hier zwei Stunden Training am Tag und gehen dann nach Hause. Keine Pflege, keine Regeneration. Also ich glaube, dieses Bewusstsein zu schaffen, Profi zu sein, das hat er glaube ich bei vielen geschafft, ja.
Und gleichzeitig ist er auch vorgelebt. Also das kommt auch bei mehreren Gesprächspartnern nochmal zur Sprache. Also er war eben auch selber früh morgens um halb acht schon mal auf dem Platz und hat Übungen gemacht, ist gelaufen. Er hat Yoga morgens um sechs gemacht, hat später mal jemand erzählt, der mit ihm zusammen gewohnt hat in einer kurzen Phase. Das war dann schon in Eupen. Also diese Überzeugung, von der du eben sprichst, das waren eben so feste Grundsätze und vielleicht kommt daher dann eben auch die emotionale Reaktion manchmal, wenn diese Grundsätze eben angegriffen und in Frage gestellt werden. Was ich interessant fand und das hast du, Mara, ja wunderbar im Buch herausgearbeitet war, also wir hatten das jetzt zwar schon mal, aber man kommt eben immer wieder darauf zurück, heute ist das normal. Also jetzt nicht alle diese Abläufe im Detail, aber diese Professionalisierung, die Wolfgang Frank eben einfach seinen Spielern beigebracht hat. Und dazu gehört eben nicht nur dieser hohe Aufwand, sondern auch dieses ständige sich weiterbilden und den Fußball ganzheitlich verstehen. Und bei Fitnessübungen zum Beispiel auch den Rumpf zu stabilisieren. Das hat Jürgen Klopp, glaube ich, erzählt, dass er sowas vorher und nachher nie wiedergemacht hat bei dem Fußballtrainer. Heutzutage ist das völlig normal, kann man sich gar nicht mehr anders vorstellen. Also er hat im Grunde den Fußball, so wie er heute ist, vorweggenommen und das schon sehr, sehr früh.
Auf jeden Fall. Und was, glaube ich, auch eine ganz, ganz wichtige Rolle spielt, ist, dass es für ihn völlig egal war, auf was für einem Niveau der Verein spielt, den er gerade trainiert. Diese Glaubenssätze, die für ihn wichtig waren und diesen Anspruch und diese Arbeitsmoral, die er eingefordert hat, die hatten nichts damit zu tun, wie hoch- oder niedrigklassig der Verein unterwegs ist. Ihr habt beide Glarus jetzt schon angesprochen, was ja natürlich eine ganz, ganz wichtige Station für ihn war. Zum einen, glaube ich, das könnte der Basti noch besser sagen, weil sie da eben als Familie auch eine sehr intensive Zeit miteinander hatten. Zum anderen aber eben auch, weil er da ja vom Spieler über den Spielertrainer zum Trainer geworden ist, weil er das Spielersein loslassen musste. Das war ja nichts Freiwilliges, sondern etwas, was eben aus der Verletzung herauskam. Und diesen Anspruch, den er da hatte, und das mit dem Vorleben, das galt in Glarus ja beispielsweise auch für die Geschichte mit dem Hauptberuf. Also weil Wolfgang Frank hat in der Zeit ja selbst auch gearbeitet, also nicht nur als Trainer, sondern eben auch im Sinne von einer Ausbildung machen und in einem Ausbildungsberuf arbeiten. Das heißt, auch da hat er diese Ansprüche eben nicht nur an die Spieler gestellt, sondern auch an sich selbst. Und aus Glarus beispielsweise gibt es ja auch die Geschichte, dass der verletzte Spieler teilweise ausgeflogen hat, sag ich mal, nach Deutschland zu Ärzten, mit denen er als Bundesligaspieler eben zu tun hatte, weil er da für sich keinen Unterschied gemacht hat. Fußball war dieses ganzheitliche Thema, und das Level des Fußballs hat dabei überhaupt keine Rolle gespielt, weil er daran geglaubt hat, dass, wenn man eben alles reingibt, man auch alles zurückbekommt. Also dieses Viel bringt viel und mehr bringt mehr, das waren ja schon auch so Glaubenssätze. Und da steckt natürlich immer auch ein gewisser Druck drin, auch auf sich selbst, aber da steckt auch eine sehr große Freiheit für eine Entwicklung drin und ein sehr großer Glaube daran, dass man eben auch was erreichen kann. Und also ich meine, wir wissen alle, dass es gesellschaftlich natürlich leider nicht richtig ist, zu sagen, wer viel investiert, bekommt auch viel zurück. Das ist was, woran unsere Gesellschaft ganz bestimmt krank, dass das eben leider nicht der Fall ist. Aber im Sport ist es natürlich ein Stück weit so, wenn du im Sport sehr viel investierst und nicht gerade durch eine Verletzung zurückgeworfen wirst, dann stehen dir eben Wege tatsächlich auch offen. Und diese Wege wollte er letztlich den Spielern auch zeigen und öffnen.
Ja, es war ja auch so, er hat ja selbst in Klarus dann auch Sachen, oder auch später, er hat ja aus eigener Tasche Sachen bezahlt, wenn es ein Verein jetzt nicht wollte, oder gesagt hat, das sehen wir jetzt nicht viel notwendig an. Oder irgendwelche Anschaffungen oder irgendwelche Leute auch anzustellen. Du sagst dazu Volker Sauter war ja damals auch so ein bisschen der erste Mental-Trainer, den er ja da engagiert hatte. Ich glaube, der hatte ja dann auch so eine Ausbildung gemacht als Mental-Trainer. Er ist eigentlich ursprünglich, ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, Christian Heidler hat mal gesagt Lokomotivführer, glaube ich, gewesen. Oder Busfahrer, was auch immer. Und er war jetzt der Überzeugung, er hatte den getroffen, auch in Mainz, und den brauchen wir jetzt. Und dann hat er ja auch, das hat er ja dann teilweise aus eigener Tasche bezahlt. Oder auch Spieler jetzt irgendwie nach Zürich gebracht von Glarus oder auch nach Freiburg zu Professor Klümper. Gesagt dazu, wir machen das jetzt, das ist wichtig, wir brauchen den Spieler fürs Wochenende. Ja, und wie Mara schon sagte, selber zu arbeiten und gleichzeitig dann noch abends die Mannschaft zu trainieren mit quasi so einem Profitum, was eigentlich keins war. Ich meine, wir auch als Familie waren ja so eingespannt. Das heißt, da ging es um diese, weiß nicht, wie man das in Deutsch sagt, Matschzeitung, also dieses Heft, wo die Annoncen drin sind. Spieltagsheft. Spieltagsheft, genau, Entschuldigung. Da kam der Schweizer gerade durch. Genau, das war dann so, die Annoncen hat er ja, er ist ja rumgefahren und unsere Mutter ja auch, die haben ja diese Annoncen versucht, an den Mann zu bringen. Das heißt, die Matschballspende, dann sind wir mit dem Leiterwagen rumgefahren, haben diese Zeitschriften in Klaus verteilt. Also es war so, es war unfassbar. Die Spieler waren bei uns zu Hause, wenn dann irgendwelche Sponsorenläufe in der Stadt waren, die haben sich da geduscht. Also das war, ich muss sagen, wenn ich so daran denke, das ist unfassbar, was er da für einen Elan und für einen Esprit und für einen Geistern heraufbeschworen hat, auch so auf dem Level, wo er sagt, hör zu, wir machen hier alles, um erfolgreich zu sein, um keine Ausrede zu haben. Und das muss ich sagen, es war für mich schon auch beeindruckend, mit welcher Akribie, mit welcher Hingabe er sein Job nachgegangen ist. Und ja, das war natürlich dann auch teilweise so, dass er dann auch übers Ziel hinausgeschossen ist. Aber er hat, glaube ich, wie Mara schon richtig gesagt hat, er hat nichts einem abverlangt, was er nicht selber bereit gewesen wäre zu geben.
Ja, und da sind wir ja auch bei einem interessanten Punkt, nämlich der Motivation aus sich selbst heraus. Wir haben das jetzt immer mal wieder schon gestreift. Wolfgang Frank hatte eben ganz klare Überzeugungen. Er hat sich auch schon sehr früh in seiner Karriere, ich glaube noch als Spieler, hat er sich schon mit Autosugession beschäftigt. Professor Enkelmann ist schon mal gefallen und Volker Sauter eben auch Mentaltrainer. Also er hat sehr früh diese Seite des Fußballs mitgedacht. Du hast geschrieben, Mara, er wollte in den Kopf seiner Spieler im positiven Sinne. Und das hat er schon mitgedacht und wurde dafür dann aber auch immer mal wieder in die esoterische Ecke gedrängt. Einmal wurde er an einer Station gefragt, welche Bäume denn seine Spieler schon umarmt hätten oder ob er die schon gepflanzt hätte, die sie umarmen sollten. Und das ist natürlich tatsächlich ein Thema, was eben mit Überzeugung und Glauben dann ein Stück weit zu tun hat. So erklärt es sich, glaube ich, dass da manche zurückhaltender sind und dass es auch nicht für jeden etwas ist. Also nicht jeder kann sich vor den Spiegel stellen und mit Sprechübungen seine Stimme schulen. Und nicht jeder zählt einfach für sich laut von 1 bis 200, weil er das auch im Training macht mit seinen Spielern. Und er eben möchte, dass seine Stimme dabei kraftvoll klingt. Aber dennoch ist es ja heutzutage viel normaler, eben über diesen mentalen Aspekt auch zu sprechen. Also auch hier wieder Wolfgang Frank sehr früh in seiner Zeit. Gleichzeitig vielleicht aber auch eine der Aspekte seiner Trainertätigkeit, die ihm vielleicht manchmal den Zugang zu manchem Spieler und vielleicht auch Präsidium versperrt hat. Würdest du das auch so ungefähr einordnen, Mara? Welche Rolle hat das gespielt?
Also einmal noch so ein bisschen vorangeschoben vielleicht der inhaltlichen Antwort, was mich sehr beschäftigt hat beim Schreiben dann, war so diese Realisierung. Er war ja ein sehr, sehr Kopfballstarker Spieler, also das war das, was ihn als Spieler sehr stark ausgemacht hat. Er hat dann diese ganzen mentalen Aspekte, also wiederum der Kopf, eben in seiner Karriere als Trainer extrem betont. Und er ist am Ende seines Lebens tatsächlich an einem Gehirntumor gestorben. Und das ist irgendwie so ein Gleichklang, über den ich echt viel nachgedacht habe, weil ich so das Gefühl habe, auch wenn man so seinen eigenen Losungen, also Franks eigenen Losungen klaut, mit dem das eben nichts zufällig ist im Leben, wie das irgendwie so zusammengeht, das finde ich schon... Ja, also das hat mich nicht so richtig losgelassen tatsächlich, wie das so ineinandergreift, so von Anfang bis Ende in seinem Leben, diese Bedeutung eben dessen, was im Kopf vor sich geht. Und davon abgesehen, wenn es jetzt um die inhaltliche Frage geht, inwiefern ihm das vielleicht das eine oder andere auch mal versperrt hat, das glaube ich schon, dass es natürlich auch Spieler gab, die gesagt haben, das ist nichts für mich. Aber zum Beispiel einer, mit dem ich darüber länger gesprochen habe in Mainz, ist der Michael Müller, der hier als Schorsch hauptsächlich bekannt ist, der gesagt hat, er konnte das so nicht. Und dann war damals der Deal so, er versuchts mal. Und zwar so, dass Wolfgang Frank das Gefühl hat, es ist ein aufrichtiger Versuch. Aber wenn er aus diesem Versuch dann rauskommt und sagt, es funktioniert immer noch nicht für mich, dann ist es auch okay. Also Frank war zwar selber von diesen Ansätzen überzeugt, aber beispielsweise diese Enkelmann-Geschichte war ja eben gerade in der Mainzer Zeit sehr wichtig. Und da sind sie dann teilweise als Mannschaft eben auch hingefahren. Und dann gab es aber einzelne Spieler, die gesagt haben, ich komme darauf einfach nicht klar. Und zwar nicht nur, ich bin nicht 100 Prozent überzeugt davon oder ich weiß nicht so genau, sondern ich empfinde das wirklich, also das passt nicht zu mir. Und das hat er dann auch akzeptiert, weil er schon dran geglaubt hat, dass Dinge eben nur mit einer Überzeugung funktionieren. Und wenn jemand diese Überzeugung nicht hatte, dann hat er ihn auch nicht gezwungen. Aber natürlich war es so, je größer die Gruppe der Spieler war, die diese Überzeugung nicht geteilt haben, umso schwieriger wurde es. Ist ja klar, wenn das ein Ansatz ist, auf den du selber persönlich so viel Wert legst, dann brauchst du den natürlich auch. Und dann brauchst du eine, ich sag mal, größere Gesamtheit von Spielern, die das natürlich mittragen. Was jetzt die anderen Vereinsverantwortlichen angeht, sind die, glaube ich, gar nicht immer so davon berührt gewesen. Also natürlich gab es eben auch so die Geschichten, dass er dann auch mal im Hotel bei einem Trainingslager eben seine Sprachübungen gemacht hat und das dann alleine von der Lautstärke her irgendwie im Hotel so auffällig wurde, wo sich dann Vereinsverantwortliche mit auseinandersetzen mussten. Aber ich glaube, für viele von den Vereinsverantwortlichen stand er im Fokus, mit was für einem Commitment er sich wirklich in seine Aufgabe geschmissen hat und schon auch die Tatsache, wie intensiv man sich, wenn man das denn wollte, mit ihm über Fußball austauschen konnte. Es gab aber auch den einen oder anderen Verein, wo er insgesamt mit diesem Ansatz an seine Grenzen gestoßen ist, was ich immer so ein bisschen lustig finde, weil es halt dafür spricht, dass sich dann Verantwortliche, die ihn engagiert haben, vorher überhaupt nicht mit ihm beschäftigt haben. Weil es war ja jetzt dann zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt schon kein Geheimnis mehr, wie er arbeitet. Und dass es dann trotzdem vielleicht noch die eine oder andere Station gab, wo die Verantwortlichen dann davon überrascht waren. Also Duisburg wäre so ein Punkt, der mir da einfällt. Ist ja eigentlich ein bisschen lustig. Aber selbst also die Duisburger Verantwortlichen haben ja jetzt so im Nachhinein mit so einem, ja, also fast so ein bisschen liebevoll auf diese Zeit zurückgeschaut. Schon so mit diesem, okay, aus unserer Sicht war das damals irgendwie schräg. Aber letztlich, ja, also auch jetzt nicht irgendwie negativ oder abschätzig oder so.
Ja, das Interessante von diesem Aspekt ist ja auch, dass dann oft so, so gerade so Autosuggestionen oder eben so positive Grundsätze, die scheinen immer vermeintlich so einfach zu sein, weil das oft sehr einfache Sätze sind. Also ich weiß nicht, ich habe das schon beim ersten Lesen, habe ich nie vergessen, dass er in einem Zitat mal gesagt hat, das war glaube ich sogar im Kicker, ja im Wort Erfolge steckt ja auch Folge. Und daraus hat er dann abgeleitet, wenn wir halt zusammen unseren Überzeugungen folgen, dann haben wir eben auch Erfolg und deswegen haben wir jetzt diese drei Spiele in Serie gewonnen. Und das ist glaube ich dann manchmal auch so, dass es ein bisschen zu einfach klingt. Gleichzeitig fand ich es aber interessant, sowohl jetzt bei dir im Buch, als auch in Interviews mit Trennen, die eben von Wolfgang Frank geprägt wurden, wie viele diese Sätze, dieser Sätze tatsächlich verfangen haben, weil sie eben auch so einfach sind und Leute sie bis heute zitieren können. Und da habe ich mir, lieber Sebastian, natürlich die Frage gestellt, welche Sätze deines Vaters sind immer in deinem Kopf und toppen immer wieder auf? Hast du da auch welche?
Boah, das gibt so die grundsätzte Lebensentfaltung von Enkelmann, wo dann auch, ja, das war ja dann auch so, dass er die ja jeden Tag irgendwo auch mit eingebracht hat. Der hat sich ja dann die bei sich zu Hause auch an den Spiegel gehangen. Und also auch so Plakate, das ist so, ich habe dann auch irgendwann mal angefangen, mir meine Wünsche aufzuschreiben, die auf Plakate dann auch irgendwie ins Wohnzimmer zu hängen.
Das Belief Palakad von Ted Lesow, das kommt eigentlich von Wolfgang Frank, jetzt haben wir es endlich verstanden.
Nein, aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, so Grundsätze, aber klar, ich meine, es ist ja auch in den Ordnern zur Sprache gekommen, die Mara dann durchgearbeitet hat. Genau das mit Erfolgen, das sind solche Themen, die er immer wieder aufgegriffen hat, die hat er sich ja dann auch immer wieder kurz notiert. Und das muss ich sagen, das mache ich viel zu wenig. Das merke ich selber, wenn ich jetzt in dem Job arbeite, sich die Dinge aufzuschreiben, Ideen, also er war da schon so gestrukturiert, dass auch diese Glaubenssätze waren ja für ihn dann immer, er musste wieder immer daran erinnert werden, weil es seiner Meinung nach auch das Unterbewusstsein, das er mit den Augen aufnimmt und dann immer wieder muss es die laut vorsagen, um entsprechend, dass es auch in Umsetzung kommt. Und ja, also ich muss sagen, ich mache das auch eigentlich noch, was ich noch regelmäßig mache, ist, dass ich, wenn ich jetzt Auto fahre, irgendwie zu einem Spiel und dann auch oft noch mich ertappe, also bzw. ich versuche es regelmäßig zu machen, mir geht es mit jedem Tag, in jeder Hinsicht mit Gottes Hilfe immer besser und besser, war immer so ein Grundsatz, wenn du sagst, das musst du dir jeden Tag sagen, 20 Mal ganz schnell, so das habe ich mir irgendwie beibehalten, dass ich das ganz oft versuche, auch wenn es sich ein bisschen schräg anhört, oder auch diese Sprachübungen. Meine Frau ertappt mich manchmal, dass ich dann zu früh quasi so das Telefon anhabe und immer noch sie mich anruft und ich da drauf komme und ich da gerade dabei bin, auch so diese, wie wir es vorher schon hatten, mit den A, E, I, O, U und das R, was er immer so gerollt hat, auch diese Aussprache zu üben, das sind schon so Dinge, wo ich auch noch heute regelmäßig mache und so eine Vibration zu erzeugen. Also ich muss sagen, das waren schon Themen, wenn das einer jetzt, keine Ahnung, zum Glück hört das ja sich niemand an hier. Es ist schon schräg auch so, aber ich muss sagen, er hat ja versucht, den Körper in eine gewisse Schwingung zu bringen. Das kannst du dich dann auch wieder so in diese esoterische Ecke schieben, aber ich fand das hochspannend und wenn du dann teilweise Sachen liest auch, der Hintergrund ist schon richtig so. Schwingung, alles ist Schwingung im Leben. Das war auch immer so ein Thema bei ihm, wie ich auf Menschen zugehe, Gegenstände, dass alles seine Schwingung hat. Also ich muss sagen, Gespräche mit ihm waren sowas von Bereichern, weil er in dem, da hat er sich auch komplett verlieren können in den Themen. Und deswegen, also bei mir ist es schon ein bisschen so im Auto, versuche ich diese Dinge ab und zu mal dann auch weiterleben zu lassen. Zum Glück hört mir da niemand zu, aber mir tut es gut. Vielleicht ist es auch immer ein bisschen eine Erinnerung an den Papa, wenn ich das mache. Von daher sind das zwei Dinge, die ich da so beibehalten habe.
Glaube führt zur Tat, Konzentration führt zum Erfolg, Wiederholung führt zur Meisterschaft. Das ist tatsächlich ein Satz, den ganz, ganz viele Spieler im Gespräch wieder aufleben lassen haben. Also was so sehr prägend für sie gewesen ist, der Sandro war unter anderem einer von denen. Das werde ich auch nicht vergessen.
Ja, lustig. Das habe ich mir hier auch rausgeschrieben, weil das auch Sandro Schwarz später nochmal in einem anderen Interview wiederholt hat. Und da ist ja schon das Element der Wiederholung mit drin. Und ich glaube, das ist noch etwas, was Wolfgang Frank als Trainer ausgezeichnet hat, fast schon bis über die Grenze manches Spielers hinaus – selbst Jürgen Klopp wurde da einmal sehr ungehalten – das ständige Repetieren und die ständige Wiederholung eben der Grundsätze der Arbeit. Und das bedeutet dann eben auch, die ersten anderthalb Stunden im Training kann es sein, dass wir jetzt erstmal nur Stangen anlaufen in unserer 4-4-2-Formation. Und erst in den zweiten anderthalb Stunden kommt dann auch mal der Ball ins Spiel. Was haben dir Spieler, die das damals erlebt haben, Mara dazu erzählt? Es ist ja auch wieder – also wir sind immer beim Thema, man muss sich darauf einlassen oder nicht. Aber er hatte ja auch an vielen Stationen damit sehr viel Erfolg. Also das 4-4-2 hatten die Teams drauf. Ich glaube, das kann man so schon sagen.
Auf jeden Fall. Und ich glaube, wir haben es ja schon ein paar Mal angesprochen, die Station, an der er in Deutschland eben zuerst mit diesem System gearbeitet hat, war tatsächlich seine erste Phase bei Mainz 05. Damals stand die Mannschaft eben richtig schlecht da, also war Tabellenletzter, ist auch, nachdem er dann Anfang September gekommen ist, bis zur Winterpause, was also nicht zur Saisonhalbzeit, sondern ich glaube zwei Spiele davor war, Tabellenletzter gewesen. Und dann, muss man sagen, waren sie quasi so am Ende als Verein, dass es eine Offenheit dafür gab, zu sagen, wir machen jetzt eben dieses neue System. Und dann hatte man eben diese sehr lange Winterpause, in der er angefangen hat, das mit den Spielern zu machen. Und natürlich gab es dann erstmal, ich würde es Irritationen nennen darüber, was das jetzt plötzlich irgendwie soll. Aber wenn du nichts zu verlieren hast und natürlich als Sportler den Wunsch, den Karren noch irgendwie aus dem Dreck zu ziehen, dann hast du eben, glaube ich, die notwendige Offenheit dafür. Und ich sag mal, zu dem Zeitpunkt war diese Mannschaft ja jetzt zumindest von ihm schon gewohnt, dass man jetzt nicht so ganz wenig trainiert. Das heißt, da haben sich ja dann erstmal hauptsächlich die Inhalte geändert. Aber diese Wiederholung, ich glaube, dass das ein schmaler Grat ist, dass man eben auf der einen Seite dann als Verantwortlicher vermittelt. Je mehr wir das wiederholen, umso mehr geht es uns quasi in die DNA über. Du willst ja eigentlich erreichen, dass du jemanden nachts um vier wächst und er macht genau das Richtige. Das soll die Wiederholung ja eigentlich bringen, dass es sich so einprägt, dass es quasi ein Teil von dir wird. Ich glaube, letztlich ist die Frage immer, wie groß ist die Offenheit? Mein Eindruck war, dass, wenn man jetzt auf das rein Sportliche geht, es weniger Widerstände gegen das Was gab an den Orten, wo er auch mit Widerständen zu kämpfen hatte, als gegen das Wie. Das Wie bedeutete dann diese kompletten Fußball-Tage, dass man nicht nur eine Trainingseinheit hat und dann wieder heim ist, sondern dass man den ganzen Tag irgendwie dahingegangen ist. Gleichzeitig gibt es aber auch ganz viele von seinen ehemaligen Spielern, die sagen, natürlich auf einem niedrigeren Level, also nicht, dass du drei Stunden die Sachen jeden Tag wiederholst, aber dieses Thema Wiederholung an sich haben sie für sich beibehalten, auch an ihrer heutigen eigenen Trainer-Tätigkeit. Das ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll. Also auch da muss man sagen, war er letztlich seinerzeit einen Schritt voraus. Er hat es dann sicherlich in der Intensität, würde man auch wiederum aus heutiger Sicht sagen, übertrieben an der einen oder anderen Stelle. Also es war dann irgendwann auch zu viel. Er hat auf der Suche nach dem perfekten Maß sicherlich sich eher ein bisschen auf der Zu-Viel-Seite bewegt. Aber so ist es dann halt manchmal. Dafür gab es halt zu dieser Zeit sehr viele andere, die sicherlich irgendwie zu wenig gemacht haben, wenn man denn diese Maßstäbe irgendwie so anlegen kann. Aber letztlich hat er die Mannschaften, die er trainiert hat, größtenteils erreicht mit dem, was er gemacht hat. Und das hatte auch damit logischerweise zu tun, dass es ja Früchte getragen hat. Das ist ja nicht so, dass er im luftleeren Raum mit den Jungs irgendwas gemacht hat, sondern sie haben ja dann auf dem Platz gesehen, dass sich Dinge tatsächlich verbessern, wenn sie sich an das halten, was er von ihnen möchte.
Und dennoch muss das eine intensive Zeit gewesen sein, dieses eine Bild, das Jürgen Klopp verwendet hat, dass man bei den Mannschaftsbesprechungen auf so Campingstühlen gesessen sei und wenn sie dann aufgestunden wären nach drei Stunden, dann hätten sie alle die Rillen noch Tage später im Rücken gehabt. Irgendwie dieses Bild bin ich nicht los geworden. Das ist einfach sehr plastisch. Und da hat ihm ja auch einmal gesagt, du versuchst ein Glas Wasser mit einem Eimer zu füllen. Da wurde es dann kurz emotionaler zwischen den beiden. Aber Sebastian, gleichzeitig war das ja vielleicht auch eine Folge dessen, dass dein Vater so viel zu vermitteln hatte und dass er auch immer auch noch Expertenmeinungen mit dazu gehut hat. Also wir haben jetzt schon Volker Sauter angesprochen und die mentale Seite des Ganzen. Es gab aber zum Beispiel auch schon sehr früh in Mainz eine Kooperation mit Professor Augustin von der Uni Mainz, der letztlich im Grunde so taktisches Scouting vorweggenommen hat, wie es heute völlig normal ist. Das fand ich auch total interessant zu sehen, dass das in einer Zeit, in der es eben noch nicht die Datenbanken gab oder die Anbieter, also damals könnte man noch nicht über Y-Scout und wen es da so alles gibt, alle Spiele sehen, dass er das schon sehr früh gemacht hat, sich auch wissen, von außen heranzuholen.
Ja, ich glaube, er war da auch nicht eitel. Also ich glaube, das ist ja das, wo vielleicht der eine oder andere sagt, ich weiß vermeintlich schon alles und lasse da keine Expertenmeinungen zu. Er war da immer offen, er war neugierig und hat sich da gerne ausgetauscht. Ich muss sagen, das ist irgendwie was ja auch naheliegend, aber man muss ja trotzdem auch erstmal auf die Idee kommen, du hast am Bruchweg dein Trainingszentrum und neben dran ist die Uni. Um dann zu sagen, okay, ich glaube, das kam auch damals über Harald Strutz, der Kontakt mit Prof. Augustin zustande. Die haben sich da öfters getroffen, weiß ich noch, mit Helena mittags auch darüber gesprochen, auch Studenten mit eingebunden. Es war ja damals auch noch viel komplizierter als es heute ist mit VHS und wie du das überhaupt zurechtschneidest, das kann man ja gar nicht mehr als sich vorstellen. Das ist ja über 20 Jahre her. Und trotzdem hat man versucht, da schon so diese Anfänge, wo es heute eigentlich USOS ist, bei Vereinen Analyse-Tools zu entwickeln, um sich entsprechend auf die Gegner vorzubereiten. Und er da immer offen war, von anderen Gebieten zu lernen, von anderen Experten zu lernen, das war immer für ihn selbstverständlich. Der hat das immer gesucht, den Austausch. Und das hat ihn auch ausgezeichnet, finde ich, als Trainer da auch, Meinungen zuzulassen und da auch das Beste mitzunehmen für seine eigene Arbeit.
Bei Professor Augustin beziehungsweise bei der Zusammenarbeit mit Professor Augustin muss man auch sagen, was natürlich auch eine Rolle gespielt hat, war, dass der mit seinen Studierenden ja eben auch die 05-Spiele angeschaut hat, also dass es nicht nur um eine Gegnerbetrachtung ging, sondern auch darauf zu schauen, welche Fehler in unserem Spiel wiederholen sich und wie stellen wir sie ab. Und das andere, was da sicherlich ein großer Schritt für ihn gewesen ist, was auch tatsächlich aus der Hand zu geben. Weil irgendwann kannst du dich halt nicht mehr um alles alleine kümmern. Und Basti hat es vorhin ja auch schon angesprochen, Wolfgang Frank hat sehr, sehr früh schon gerade auch diese Gegnerbetrachtung gemacht. Also in seinen Unterlagen auch aus der Zeit in der Schweiz gibt es eben genau immer diese Geschichten, dass er vor den Spielen Spiele der Gegner anschaut, dass er sich ganz genau aufschreibt, was sind die Stärken und Schwächen der einzelnen Spiele, wie können sie einen Spieler ausschalten, auf wen müssen sie besonders achten, was müssen sie da irgendwie im Blick haben. Und er hat jetzt nicht aufgehört, diese Gegnerbeobachtung auch selbst zu machen, aber er hat eben nach und nach auch angefangen, sich dabei eben auf andere zu verlassen, die ihm gewisse Grunddaten auf jeden Fall eben schon mal zusammenstellen. Also dieses mit dem Wachsen der Aufgaben, die er für sich begreift, und das waren bei ihm, das haben wir jetzt schon mehrfach angesprochen, eben ohnehin, also sicherlich deutlich mehr als bei vielen anderen Trainern zu dieser Zeit, hat er dann irgendwann nicht sehr leicht, aber schon ein Stück weit, glaube ich, auch gelernt, zuzulassen, dass er nicht alles immer zu 100 Prozent alleine machen kann, sondern dass er eben auch andere Leute mit rein nimmt, auf die er sich verlassen kann, wo er dann eben auch ein Vertrauensverhältnis hat.
Und dann hatte er ja schon in der Saison 99 2000 auch zum ersten Mal einen Co-Trainer. Ja, aber man kann da auch ganz gut, finde ich, nacherzählen, wie eben einfach auch die Wissensfülle im Fußball dann immer größer geworden ist. Und da war eben dann Wolfgang Frank aus verschiedenen Gründen früher dran als ganz viele andere in Deutschland. Und heutzutage ist es aber etwas – also Jürgen Klopp sagt ja auch, dass er zum Beispiel auch deshalb, weil er das bei Wolfgang Frank gesehen hätte, auch selbst so viele externe Spezialisten oder interne Spezialisten, muss man bei ihm sagen, um sich herum hat und auch andere Meinungen dann zulassen kann. Und als ich dann versucht habe, so ein bisschen für mich zusammenzufassen, Sebastian, was jetzt eigentlich dann das ist, was deinen Vater anders unterschieden hat von anderen Trainern, da ist mir ein Zitat ins Auge gesprungen, und zwar von Sven Demann, der ist jetzt Scout bei Holstein Kiel, war auch schon als Trainer aktiv und eben Spieler unter Wolfgang Frank. Und er hat gesagt, ich hatte sicher 20, 25 Trainer, aber nur einen, der mir den großen Plan vom Fußball erklärt hat und wie wichtig mannschaftliche Geschlossenheit dafür ist. Und unter anderem wird das auch darin im Buch erklärt, dass er bei Gegentoren immer darauf hingewiesen hat, dass es eigentlich fast immer ein mannschaftstaktischer Fehler war, der ein Tor entstehen hat lassen und eben nicht nur der eine Verteidige da hinten den Fehler gemacht hat. Ist das vielleicht das Erbe deines Vaters, dass er den Fußball früher als viele andere, als ein Kollektivsport verstanden hat?
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja auch so ein Thema, wo auch selbst, ich kann mich noch erinnern, auch Thomas Tuchel hat das ja dann auch später, das habe ich jetzt bewusst in Erinnerung, auch von Schwarmintelligenz gesprochen hat zum Beispiel. Das sind ja so ähnliche Themen, wo du davon ausgehst, als Kollektiv musst du funktionieren. Das sind ja dann am Schluss auch nicht nur elf Spieler, sondern auch noch das ganze Drumherum. Ich glaube, er hat einen Verein als gesamte Einheit gesehen, die funktionieren muss. Vom Zeugwart bis zur Putzfrau, was weiß ich. Ich glaube, darum war ihm auch so wichtig, dass man sich um alle kümmert, dass sich alle wohlfühlen, dass man nur dann auch, wenn man eine besondere Stimmung erzeugt, einen besonderen Geist in den Verein bekommt, Großes erreichen kann. Ich glaube, das ist nicht nur auf die Mannschaft gemünzt, sondern generell im Club. Das hat er versucht zu leben, dass er dann auch jedem den entsprechenden Respekt entgegengebracht hat, geguckt hat, dass er auch genug verdient, dass er sich wohlfühlt, dass er sich 100%ig auch seine Aufgabe widmen kann. Ich glaube, wie gesagt, das ist nicht nur dann auf den Kader beschränkt, sondern generell im Club. Und das finde ich immer auch eine großartige Sache, dass du auch dieses soziale Gespür hast, wie wichtig jeder Einzelne ist. Also ich meine, auch beim FC Aarau weiß ich noch, wie oft er dann auch beim Platzfahrt im Büro saß und sich drum gekümmert hat und gefragt hat, wie es denen geht und was er denn verändern könnte und ob sie dann zurechtkommen. Und das hat er durchgezogen bei jedem Club. Und deswegen – ich war vor ein, zwei Jahren auch in Olpen, das war ja quasi seine letzte Station – wie begeistert die Leute waren, wie er mit Menschen umgegangen ist. Und da kommen wir wieder auf die Themen zurück, die wir vorher auch schon besprochen hatten. Das ist so, was ihn komplett ausgemacht hat, dieses kollektive Denken, dass der Einzelne nicht so wichtig ist wie das große Ganze. Und das hat, glaube ich, auch ab und zu zu Konflikten geführt, weil er hatte dann auch mal Spieler dabei, die sich natürlich dem nicht so hundertprozentig unterordnen wollten. Weil für ihn war das Kollektiv fast wichtiger als der einzelne Spieler. Weil er meistens auch Mannschaften hatte, die individuell nicht so gut waren. Und er hatte aber immer – das war für mich sowieso immer faszinierend – er kam irgendwo hin und du hast zeitnah gemerkt, die Mannschaften fangen nach einer gewissen Zeit an, weniger Tore zu kriegen, mehr Spiele zu gewinnen. Und das war schon so. Und diese Kraft und das zu sehen in einer Mannschaft, wo stelle ich wen hin, dass er die Aufgabe am besten erfüllt für den Teamgedanke, das war bei ihm immer das Wichtigste. Er hat dann aus vermeintlich schlechteren Spielern eine bessere Mannschaft gemacht. Das ist so, wo ich sage, das können nicht viele Trainer, glaube ich. Und dann auch ein Verein dahingehend zu entwickeln. Auch in Mainz hat er dann auch viel kritisiert. Ich glaube, er ging auch um Christian Heidel dann auch teilweise tierisch auf den Zeiger mit den ganzen Forderungen. Aber ich glaube, ihm war es immer wichtig, so eine Entwicklung im Klub zu sehen, die Leute mitzunehmen. Klar, er war halt ungeduldig, aber generell war das halt schon immer ein Anliegen. Ich glaube, es ging nicht mehr um seinen eigenen Erfolg, sondern er hatte Lust darauf gehabt, mit einer Gruppe etwas zu erreichen, eine Vision zu haben. Das ist so ein bisschen, was ihn, finde ich, ausgezeichnet hat. Er hat sich immer eine Vision für eine Gruppe so ein bisschen vorgestellt. Und das ist so etwas, was, glaube ich, nicht viele Leute können. Das ist etwas zu sehen, was nicht da ist, aber was irgendwann entstehen kann. Und heute gehst du nach Mainz ins Stadion und es ist fast schon selbstverständlich, dass Mainz seit so vielen Jahren Bundesliga spielt, wo er vor 25 Jahren drüber gesprochen hat und gesagt hat, warum sollen wir nicht Bundesliga irgendwann mal spielen? Und ich glaube, kein Einziger hat jemals daran geglaubt, dass Mainz wirklich mal so ein Bestandteil der Bundesliga wird. Und das so Aussagen auch zu treffen, ist ja auch mutig, weil du wirst ja viele drinnen sagen, erzähl in der Frank-Hier, Bundesliga, wir sind hier Abschiebskampf, zweite Liga, guck dir die Infrastruktur an. Das ist so, wo man im Kollektiv einfach, das hat, finde ich, meins ist ein Paradebeispiel dafür, was man da entwickeln kann.
Und auch so diese totale Überzeugung, dass eine Gruppe eben mehr ist als die Summe ihrer Teile. Und das ist letztlich, man muss an gar nicht mal so vielen Stellschrauben drehen, um eben das zu erreichen, also dass eine Gruppe über sich hinaus wachsen kann, durch dieses Kollektiv.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir, glaube ich, auch hier schon einen Hinweis darauf bekommen, warum Meins 05 Wolfgang Frank so für sich reklamiert. Denn da ist es eben einfach. Also er ist nicht mit Meins 05 aufgestiegen, auch wenn seine ehemaligen Spieler sagen, Mensch, wenn er da noch ein bisschen geblieben wäre, dann hätten wir es mit ihm zusammen gemacht. Später ist er Meins aufgestiegen und eben viele bekannte heutige Trainer kommen eben von Meins und wurden eben alle von Wolfgang Frank geprägt und mit Jürgen Klopp hat man da den Allerbekanntesten. Jetzt schon häufig genug haben wir den genannt. Ich hatte beim Lesen des Buches, also ich habe es ja zum zweiten Mal gelesen, Mara, immer mal wieder den Gedanken, also es gab diesen Zeitpunkt, in dem war Wolfgang Frank seiner Zeit sehr voraus. Und das, was aber Mitte der 90er revolutionär war, wurde dann so langsam ab 2005 ungefähr, würde ich sagen, zum Standard. Also, dass man Viererketten spielt, dass man mit Raumdeckung spielt. Und heute leben wir in einer Zeit, wo man es sich eigentlich kaum noch erlaubt, in nur einem System zu spielen, sondern man muss eben flexibel sein und so weiter. Und das ist ja auch alles jetzt durchverwissenschaftlich, der Fußball. Was sagt denn die Karriere und der Verlauf der Karriere von Wolfgang Frank über den Innovationsdruck aus, den Trainer vielleicht auch haben?
Also ich würde mal sagen, dadurch, dass er sehr, sehr früh schon sehr innovativ war, wie wir jetzt schon mehrfach angesprochen haben, bis zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt gar nicht so viel. Ab einer gewissen zeitlichen Grenze, würde ich sagen, hat er es vermutlich so ein bisschen verpasst, auch die Offensive wieder stärker in den Blick zu nehmen. Ich würde tatsächlich sagen, dass das dann auch in Mainz nach seinem Weggang und nach den Zwischenschritten, die es dann noch gab, das ist, was Wolfgang – Wolfgang Klopp, sag ich schon. Da sieht ihr mal, so sehr verschmelzen die beiden. Nein, aber das ist, glaube ich, das, was tatsächlich Jürgen Klopp dann auch eben als Weiterentwicklung geschafft hat. Also dass er eben das, was er von Wolfgang Frank mitgenommen hat, als Basis benutzt hat. Aber sich eben auch mehr Gedanken gemacht hat, um das, was machen wir eigentlich in der Offensive. Basti hat es gerade schon angesprochen, dass die Teams, die er übernommen hat, relativ schnell weniger Gegentore bekommen haben. Aber so der ganz große Plan auch für ein Offensivspiel und für die eigenen Tore, der ist irgendwann in der Entwicklung sicherlich nicht mehr weitergegangen. Und das ist tatsächlich auch etwas, was ich sagen würde, das bestätigt sich eigentlich in dem, was seine ehemaligen Spieler über ihn berichten. Da gab es auch die Situation mit Jogi Löw, der so meinte, er ist daran so ein bisschen verzweifelt, damals schon, dass es eben so sehr stark um die Defensive ging. Natürlich weiß man längst, wie wichtig eine Defensive eben ist. Aber du musst dir halt auch ein paar Gedanken darum machen, wie du Tore schießen möchtest. Und ich glaube, da er ja selber ein Stürmer war, war das für einige seiner Spieler auch sehr überraschend, dass er sich damit nicht so sehr beschäftigt hat. Aber er hat bis zum Schluss ja in Interviews immer gesagt, wenn man von einem System überzeugt ist, dann reicht eben dieses eine System auch. Und das war aber am Ende vielleicht so ein bisschen der Punkt, wo ihm dann ja die Offenheit oder die Vision ein bisschen gefehlt hat ab einem gewissen Punkt. Was mache ich eigentlich vorne?
Hast du da Gedanken zu, Sebastian?
Boah, ich widerspreche Mara ungern. Nein, ich glaube, ich gebe dir total ein Recht. Aber ich glaube, die Prägung ist ja klar von ihm. Er ist natürlich italienischer Fußballer, war für ihn Ordnung gegen den Ball. Das war ein großes Thema. Aber ich glaube, er hatte auch immer wieder Phasen drin gehabt, wo auch da trotzdem sein Offensivspiel, auch in Mainz oder Haching oder sonst wo, glaube ich, schon sich entwickelt hat. Ich glaube, er war einfach auch nicht lange genug, teilweise in den Vereinen, um das auch so weiter zu spinnen, glaube ich, um so eine Entwicklung voranzutreiben. Er hat dann auch zu schnell oftmals in den Sack gehauen, hat dann aber auch, sagen wir mal, aus vermeintlich schlechteren Spielern, wie ich es schon öfters angedeutet habe, gute Teams geformt. Aber dann diesen nächsten Schritt zu gehen, hat ihm teilweise, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen die Zeit und die Geduld gefehlt, weil er dann ja auch wieder weg ist. Aber es gab immer wieder Phasen, wo ich auch sage, in Offenbach, wo dann auf einmal Offenbach, glaube ich, Mainz in Fünf geschlagen hatte in der zweiten Liga, Klopova-Trainer in Mainz, wo du schon gesehen hast, dass er schon auch, ich glaube schon, Ideen hatte, auch nach vorne. Aber klar, Frank wird natürlich in erster Linie darauf reduziert zu sagen, ok, Defensiv, Ordnung, einen Verein zu stabilisieren, zu retten. Das war ja dann auch so ein bisschen so sein Ruf. Und deswegen haben wir ihn in den Clubs auch geholt, weil sie wussten, wenn wir einen Frank holen, kriegen wir einen tendenziellen Trainer, der uns retten kann mit einem höheren Wahrscheinlichkeit, als das ein anderer tut. Aber ja, keine Ahnung, ich würde das jetzt mit fehlender Vision nicht so benennen. Ich bin auch befangen, klar. Und ich auch weiß, wie er so gedacht hat. Aber klar, das Wichtigste war für ihn schon die Defensive. Aber ich glaube auch, er hatte einfach meistens mit so Teams zu tun, wo es einfach erst mal eine Linie darum ging, das zu stabilisieren und da Ergebnisse zu erzielen zu müssen. Und der nächste Schritt wäre dann gewesen, dann eine Mannschaft zu entwickeln. Und da hat er vielleicht auch selber einfach zu wenig Geduld gehabt, diesen Prozess zuzulassen und auch selber mitgehen zu können. Sondern er ist dann halt oftmals wieder woanders hingegangen, weil ihm generell die Entwicklung im Klub und auch mit der Mannschaft nicht schnell genug ging. Du hast selten von ihm gehört, wenn du über einen Spieler gefragt hast, wie findest du den? Ja, der ist nicht schlecht. Was heißt er nicht schlecht? Ist er gut, ist er nicht gut? Der hat halt auch, muss ich sagen, in jedem Spieler immer was Gutes gesehen. Das war vielleicht auch so ein bisschen typisch Trainer, weil er immer, oder er hat den Menschen immer gesehen, und der hat selten schlecht über einen Spieler gesprochen. Wenn da irgendwelche Leute nach ihm gefragt hatten, ja du hattest den in offenbar, wie ist denn der? Ja du, den kannst du schon gebrauchen, der ist nicht schlecht. Der war auch nie so, dass er irgendwie einfach mal schlecht über seine Spieler gesprochen hat.
Du kannst ja nicht in jeden deiner Berichte reinschreiben.
Ja, das ist nicht schlecht. Selbst Christian Heydl hat es mir irgendwann mal gesagt, der Wolfgang, du, wir hätten ja einen Kader von 50 Leuten haben können, weil bei jedem Spieler hat er irgendwo was gesehen und jeden mochte er und jeder hat irgendwo eine Qualität. Er hat sich das schwer getan, auch klar zu benennen, was brauche ich oder was kann der Spieler nicht, sondern er hat auch versucht, immer das Positive zu sehen, was dann auch vielleicht in dem Job manchmal auch ein bisschen nachteilig ist, wenn du eine Entwicklung möchtest im Klub, musst du halt auch dem einen oder anderen vielleicht mal ein bisschen wehtun und sagen dazu, es reicht einfach nicht mehr. Und ja, ich gebe zu Teilen Mara recht, aber ich glaube trotzdem hat er auch Phasen immer gehabt in Vereinen, wo er das auch konnte. Aber technenziell ist es schon eher einer gewesen, der, klar, Defensive Ordnung, das war für ihn, und das war für Kloppo auch, glaube ich, die Basis von seinem Arbeiten auch als Spieler, das mitzubekommen und darauf aufzusatteln und zu sagen, ich entwickle da nochmal für mich eine andere Herangehensweise, die ihn dann so erfolgreich gemacht hat, wie sie ihn erfolgreich gemacht hat.
Aber ganz wichtig, also nur, dass das jetzt nicht irgendwie falsch hängen bleibt, die Frage von Max vorher war ja die nach quasi der Weiterentwicklung. Also ich glaube nicht, dass er prinzipiell keine Vision dafür hatte, wie er eben auch nach vorne spielen wollte. Ich glaube nur, dass er sie ab einem gewissen Zeitpunkt vielleicht zur Mitte der 2000er nicht mehr weiterentwickelt hat.
Ja, und gleichzeitig zeigt sich da dran vielleicht auch einfach, das ist halt das große Grundproblem des Fußballs, dass es einfacher ist, gegen den Ball zu spielen, als mit dem Ball zu spielen. Und das kann man ja unter anderem an der Karriere von Jürgen Klopp auch wunderbar nachvollziehen. Er hat sich das Mittel gegen das Gegenpressing, was Barcelona vor allem in den Fußball mit reingebracht hat unter Guardiola. Das war ja dann der Umschaltfußball und dann vor allem bei Borussia Dortmund waren es viele lange Bälle. Also bei Mainz waren es, glaube ich, noch eher die langen Bälle. Bei Dortmund waren es dann irgendwann so Klatsch-Pass-Tief, Klatsch-Steil-Tief-Kombinationen. Und eigentlich erst jetzt beim FC Liverpool ist es auch wirklich so, dass man eben auch mit hohen Ballbesitzzahlen, die erzwungenermaßen fast schon hat in der Premier League, jetzt auch eben einen Ballbesitzoffensivfußball umgesetzt hat. Also es ist eben auch die Königsdisziplin. Deswegen, ich wollte das auch gar nicht so kritisch verstanden wissen. Ich glaube nur, dass man eben an der Karriere deines Vaters, Sebastian, ablesen kann, wie schwierig es dann doch ist, eben auch längerfristige Dinge aufzubauen, weil man eben auch über diesen Grundsatz eigentlich kaum hinwegkommt, dass es eben ein bisschen einfacher ist, gut zu verteidigen, als es ist, gut zu stürmen. Und dafür braucht man Zeit, das hast du jetzt angesprochen. Ich fand es zum Beispiel interessant, Sandro Schwarz hat über seine Zeit bei Mainz 05 gesagt, über seine Entlassung, die es da gab, hat er gesagt. Im Nachhinein hat er reflektiert, dass er zu ungeduldig war. Da dachte ich mir, aha, das habe ich doch schon mal irgendwo gelesen, war das nicht ein Bruch von der Mara? Und dass er eben zu schnell den nächsten Schritt hätte gehen wollen. Weil da war es nämlich auch so, man stand sehr gut gegen den Ball, man war sehr gut im Anlaufen, man hatte klare Abläufe. Und dann wollte er quasi den berühmten nächsten Schritt machen, der auch immer gefordert wird von allen. Da bin ich im Rasenfunk immer ganz vorne mit dran. Ich gucke halt lieber als defensiven Fußball. Und das fand ich sehr interessant. Auch Sandro Schwarz ist seiner eigenen Aussage nach daran in Mainz 05 gescheitert. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es jetzt bei Hertha BSC macht. Da erwarten jetzt nämlich auch alle den nächsten Schritt, weil jetzt hat er ja eine Vorbereitung. Also ich finde, das sagt auch mehr fast über die Fußballbranche aus, als jetzt ganz speziell über die Personen, über die wir jetzt hier gesprochen haben, inklusive…
Absolut. Jetzt bin ich bei dir. Ich meine, auch bei Sandro war es ja so, wenn ich es recht in Erinnerung hatte, war Martin Schmidt ja quasi dann vorher Trainer, oder? Bevor Sandro dann installiert wurde. Und klar, da Martin hatte seine Art des Fußballs. Und dann war es halt, glaube ich, so ein bisschen auch… Weiß ich nicht, Sandro ist… Wie soll man sagen? Ich glaube, der kam ja als Trainer der zweiten Mannschaft, da muss ich sagen, hat er ja schon auch ein bisschen anderen Fußball spielen lassen als Martin, wo du gedacht hast, okay, das war ja auch so Thomas Tuchel Idee, mehr mit Ball zu können als jetzt nur gegen den Ball. Und du dann doch mal merkst, wie schwierig dieser Weg ist, das hinzukriegen mit Mannschaften, die vielleicht dann auch doch limitierter sind als andere, und dann auf einmal zu merken, okay, vielleicht war das dann der falsche Ansatz, vielleicht hätte ich einfach erstmal doch das beibehalten müssen. Und ja, und es ist auch schwierig, diesen nächsten Schritt zu gehen, wo ja viele Mannschaften das Problem haben, das auch noch in Ballbesitz hinzukriegen. Das ist ja dann die Königsdisziplin und da gebe ich dir recht, das ist vielleicht generell so ein Thema, wo es schwierig wird.
Ich finde, das ist was, was man auch im Fußball heute ganz klar sieht, was jetzt also den Fußball sicherlich nicht attraktiver macht, dass natürlich der Druck, die Klasse zu halten, so wahnsinnig hoch ist und dass selbst wenn ein Verein, der ich sag mal irgendwo zwischen Mittelfeld und Abstiegsrängen pendelt, mit einem Trainer arbeitet, der gerne mehr Ballbesitz hätte, sobald eben die Ergebnisse mal in diesem Ballbesitzfußball nicht da sind, wird eben wieder umgestellt, also sprich, da gibt es oft überhaupt keine Möglichkeit, mal über einen längeren Zeitraum was zu entwickeln, weil einfach dieser Ergebnisdruck so wahnsinnig hoch ist.
Das war auch so und das jetzt vielleicht dann so langsam als einer der letzten Gedanken zu Wolfgang Frank. Da habe ich auch drüber nachgedacht, ich habe mir die Frage gestellt, was wäre passiert, wenn er nicht zu früh im Alter von 62 Jahren gestorben wäre? Hätte er nicht vielleicht auch ein sehr guter Sportdirektor sein können? Er war das ja mal ganz kurz in seiner Zeit, aber das würde ich jetzt kaum gelten lassen, denn ich meine jetzt dann ein Engagement über mehrere Jahre hinweg, wo er sich einen Trainer aussuchen kann, sehr wahrscheinlich jemanden, den er selber zum Trainer gemacht hat, indirekt, und dann vielleicht länger etwas mit diesen klaren Überzeugungen hätte aufbauen können. Denn das ist schon interessant zu sehen, dass auch in diesem Punkt Wolfgang Frank eben etwas gemacht hat, was heutzutage viele Vereine wollen. Zum Beispiel, dass er eben bei Eupen dann – das war ja seine letzte Trainerstation – dass da alle Mannschaften von den Jugendteams bis eben zu den Profis nach demselben System spielen sollten, nach demselben Grund setzen. Da wollte er richtig etwas längerfristiges aufbauen. Und das, glaube ich, hätte eine Rolle sein können, in der Wolfgang Frank am richtigen Standort, wo man dafür dann vielleicht auch die Zeit bekommt, dann etwas noch größeres hätte aufbauen können. Denn das Problem – du hast es selber gerade angesprochen, Sebastian – die Trainer sind immer so schnell weg, sie haben so wenig Zeit. Mara, du hast es ja auch schon erwähnt. Und ich glaube, als etwas sportdirektorartiges hätte da vielleicht noch ein richtiges Erbe draus werden können. Also noch mehr als jetzt schon, aber eben so ein Standort, an dem er dann auch länger geblieben wäre. Das hätte ich unheimlich gerne noch gesehen.
Ja, ich glaube, das war ja auch so ein Gespräch jetzt kurz vor seinem Tod, beziehungsweise bevor das da mit der Erkrankung losging, dass er da mit dem einen oder anderen Club dann auch im Gespräch war, auch jetzt gerade was so eine Sportdirektorenposition betrifft. Ich glaube schon auch, aber ich glaube, er hätte schon Mühe gehabt, davon loszulassen, weil ich glaube, er war trotzdem ein Typ, der gerne auf dem Rasen stand und mit seinen Jungs da Dinge entwickelt hat. Was ich, glaube ich, gesehen hätte, war, wo ich mit meinem Bruder auch öfters drüber gesprochen hätte, eigentlich hätte der DFB mal so jemanden für eine Jugendmannschaft holen müssen, wo ich sage, wenn ich sehe, wer da beim DFB alles arbeitet, und dann hast du einen mit der Expertise, auch mit der Erfahrung, da muss ich sagen, ich glaube, der hätte jüngeren Spielern da auch, gerade beim DFB mal, so viel mitgeben können und auch da vielleicht so in einem Gremium zu sitzen, zu sagen, was machen wir anders, welche Ansätze haben wir. Ich glaube, das wäre auch so ein spannender Punkt gewesen, wo man vielleicht auch von DFB-Seite vielleicht mal solche Leute einzubinden, jetzt nicht nur irgendwie jüngere Trainer oder gerade die jetzt irgendwo vielleicht mal gerade gescheitert sind. Ich finde, da müsste man mal irgendwie, hätte man mal überlegen können, so jemanden zu holen. Aber das war nur so ein Gedankengang von uns jetzt. Aber ich glaube, Sportdirektor wäre durchaus auch für ihn eine Option gewesen, auch in einem reiferen Alter schon, wo du sagst, du gibst da vielleicht eher was mit, mit jüngeren Trainern auch, mit dem Austausch und dann Verein zu entwickeln auf der Position. Ich glaube schon, das wäre auch für ihn bestimmt eine interessante Möglichkeit gewesen.
Ich wollte was komplett anderes noch sagen, deswegen, was diese Sportdirektorentätigkeit angeht. Wir haben vorhin schon so ein bisschen über die Arbeit an dem Buch gesprochen. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob ihr noch irgendwie zwei, drei Anekdoten habt, berichtet. Aber eine meiner irgendwie wirklich lustigsten Anekdoten im Rückblick war, dass es dieses eine Jahr gab in der Zeit von Wolfgang Frank, das sich nirgendwo finden ließ. Und ich habe mich wirklich wundrecherchiert. Es gab diese Trainertätigkeiten in der Schweiz und zwischen zwei Trainertätigkeiten klaffte ein Jahr. Und dann hast du schon so gesehen, dass es auch anderen aufgefallen. Und in so bestimmten Datenbanken wurde dann einfach die Tätigkeit in dem einen Jahr ein Jahr verlängert oder die in dem anderen Verein ein Jahr vorgezogen. Und es war aber klar, dass es nicht stimmt, weil halt jeweils eben ein anderer Trainer für diese Phase in den Datenbanken auch übereinstimmend war. Also irgendwas konnte da nicht stimmen. Und ich habe – also, was einem so eingefallen ist, ich meine, es war halt natürlich schwierig, dass es ausgerechnet ein Schweizer Jahr war, wäre er in der Zeit in Deutschland gewesen, hättest du das locker irgendwo nachschauen können. So gab es einfach irgendwie überhaupt keine Möglichkeit. Ich habe in allen möglichen Varianten irgendwie gesucht und recherchiert und dann natürlich am Ende auch immer wieder gegoogelt. Und am Schluss habe ich wirklich auch so sehr kurz vor der Abgabe auf so einer eBay-ähnlichen Datenbank in der Schweiz Autogrammkarten gefunden. Aus genau diesem Jahr von dem Verein, in dem er eben zuvor als Trainer tätig war. Und es waren tatsächlich irgendwie sieben oder acht Autogrammkarten. Und eine der Autogrammkarten war die von Wolfgang Frank. Und dann stand halt eben drunter Sportdirektor. Ich dachte so, yes, das gibt es doch nicht. Endlich habe ich diese Lücke geschlossen. Und dann habe ich es dem Basti geschrieben. Und der Basti war so, ah ja, klar, jetzt fällt es mir auch wieder ein.
Ich meine, das war echt wieder ein... Das war echt wieder ein... Ich hab lange drüber nachgedacht, da war ich irgendwie gar nicht mehr präsent. Und dann wurde gesagt, das ist ja stimmt, er war ja noch mal Sportdirektor, aber das war so irgendwie 91 oder so was, glaube ich 90, 91, weiß ich mehr, genau. Das war dann irgendwie ja schon witzig.
So ein Armer, bevor er dann nach Wettin gegangen ist. Genau, also das mit den Autogrammkarten, das war echt der Hammer.
Und welche Lieblingsanektoten hast du sonst noch?
Also eine Anekdote, die eigentlich gar nicht witzig ist, sondern die mir so unfassbar leid tut, deswegen würde ich es gerne einmal irgendwie erzählen, ist tatsächlich, dass also eines der frühesten Gespräche, die ich geführt habe für das Buch, war mit Rainer Hollmann. Und das war wirklich ganz, ganz großartig. Und der hat mir sehr, sehr viele Einblicke gegeben, hat mir sehr viele Sachen erzählt, die sich dann später auch so in anderen Gesprächen bestätigt haben. Und als das Buch aus dem Druck kam, und dann ist es irgendwie so, ich weiß auch nicht warum, dass ich mir dann immer noch mal so meine Danksagung durchlese, weil in dieser Danksagung halt total viel so über die Arbeit an dem Buch für mich drin steckt. Bei dem Buch natürlich ganz besonders, weil es halt eben so wahnsinnig viele Leute waren, mit denen ich gesprochen habe. Und dann fehlte Rainer Hollmann in der Danksagung. Und es war ganz fürchterlich. Ich habe wirklich angefangen zu heulen vor Schreck und ich konnte es mir erst überhaupt nicht erklären. Und dann war es aber relativ offensichtlich, weil tatsächlich genau Eintracht Braunschweig eine Station ist, wo ich mit jemandem gesprochen habe, der am Schluss gesagt hat, er möchte bitte doch nicht namentlich erwähnt werden. Und wie das dann manchmal so ist, ich habe halt statt den Namen zu markieren, den kompletten Blog Eintracht Braunschweig markiert und habe das hinten rausgelöscht. Und damit war dann auch Rainer Hollmann verschwunden. Was dann zur Folge hatte, dass der erste Tag, als ich das Buch in der Hand gehalten habe, dann einer war, an dem ich so ein unfassbar schweres Herz hatte, weil ich sie überhaupt nicht irgendwie glauben konnte. Und dann habe ich ihn versucht eben zu erreichen. Und er war dann zu dem Zeitpunkt gerade auch beruflich im Ausland unterwegs. Und zum Glück haben wir dann im Nachgang ein sehr, sehr nettes Telefonat geführt. Er hat sich dann gemeldet und war ganz, ganz super. Und ich hoffe jetzt sehr, dass das Buch manchmal in eine zweite Auflage geht, damit ich Rainer Heumann in die Danksagung setzen kann, weil er hat das nämlich sehr verdient. Genau, das ist eine Geschichte. Eine Sache, die mir auch so ein bisschen abseitig vielleicht sehr in Erinnerung geblieben ist, die so ein bisschen was darüber sagt, wie emotional verbunden sich viele Leute mit ihm gefühlt haben. Ich habe gesagt, Basti und auch Benni und ich sind während des Schreibens immer sehr eng im Austausch gewesen. Basti hat bis zum Schluss immer noch Benni jemanden eingefallen, das gesagt hat, hier, da könntest du auch mal noch irgendwie sprechen und so. Es gab jemanden, mit dem ich dann sehr spät Kontakt aufgenommen habe, der auch bis zu dem Zeitpunkt nichts davon mitbekommen hatte, dass das Buch eben in der Entstehung ist, der dann eben von mir gehört hat, dass es im Prinzip schon kurz vor Abschluss ist und denen das emotional komplett aus der Bahn gehauen hat, dass er quasi zu so einem späten Zeitpunkt erst angesprochen wird. Der ist in dem Telefonat dann, muss man sagen, wirklich komplett ausgeflippt, hat mich irgendwie beschimpft und ist irgendwie ausgerastet. Und ich hatte den Impuls, erst den Hörer einfach aufzuknallen, weil ich dachte, ich muss mich ja hier irgendwie nicht so angehen lassen. Und habe dann aber zum Glück schnell genug geschaltet, dass ich so dachte, ich habe so viele krasse positive Emotionen in Bezug auf Wolfgang Frank erlebt. Und das, was da jetzt gerade passiert, das hatte überhaupt nichts irgendwie mit mir zu tun. Und das hat auch letztlich wahrscheinlich nur sekundär mit Wolfgang Frank zu tun, sondern das hat einfach was mit einer Verletzung zu tun, die da gerade wieder aufreißt. Und habe dann deswegen so quasi einmal tief durchgeatmet und gesagt, ich würde vorschlagen, ich lege jetzt einfach auf und ich würde mich in zwei, drei Tagen noch mal melden. Und er kann sich ja vielleicht bis dahin überlegen, ob er seine Meinung zu dem Thema ändert. Also weil er hat gesagt, er spricht auf keinen Fall mit mir, das ist viel zu spät alles. Und das wird eh ein scheiß Buch, weil ich jetzt erst mit ihm rede und so. Und ich war wirklich ziemlich fertig hinterher. Also ich habe es zwar geschafft, irgendwie am Telefon so die Fassung zu bewahren, ich habe aber auch da tatsächlich hinterher erst mal da gesessen und habe so vor Schreck irgendwie ein bisschen vor mich hingeweint und habe dann aber zwei, drei Tage später tatsächlich nochmal angerufen. Und das Gespräch fing dann mit einer sehr, sehr umfänglichen Entschuldigung meines Gegenübers an, weil es eben wirklich genau das war. Also da war eine so große, das Gefühl einer so großen Verbundenheit und einer so großen Berührtheit miteinander, dass dem in dem Moment einfach – er hat dann natürlich auch schon lange nicht mehr über Wolfgang Frank gesprochen oder mit jemand anderem gemeinsam über ihn nachgedacht – und dem hat es in dem Moment so die Schuhe ausgezogen, mit diesem Namen und mit dieser Geschichte, die er auch mit ihm selber hat, konfrontiert zu sein, dass er einfach die Vorstellung nicht gepackt hat, dass er die Rolle, die er für sich selbst empfindet, vielleicht am Ende irgendwie im Buch nicht haben würde. Und das war dann ein richtig, richtig gutes Gespräch, in dem ich auch noch mal echt viel erfahren habe über ihn, was auch dazu geführt hat, dass ich ein im Prinzip fast schon fertiges Kapitel noch mal sehr viel ausführlicher machen konnte, als ich es eigentlich zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte. Also das ist sicherlich was, was mir sehr in Erinnerung geblieben ist. Und zwei Sachen vielleicht noch. Ich versuche es so ein bisschen in Kürze. Der Basti hat es ja schon angesprochen. Wolfgang Frank war über viele, viele Jahre eben mit der Mutter seiner Söhne verheiratet, hat aber später auch noch mal eine Beziehung und auch noch mal eine kurze, also die Ehe war dann letztlich nur sehr kurz, gehabt mit der Maristella Kovre, mit der ich eben auch gesprochen habe. Und als ich die das erste Mal erreicht habe, war sie gerade in der Tierklinik, tatsächlich mit dem Hund, den sie sich zusammen mit Wolfgang Frank, der ja 2013 gestorben ist, so etwa zwei Jahre vor seinem Tod, ja angeschafft hat. Und die Leute, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, von den ganz späten Stationen, also hauptsächlich Eupen eigentlich, haben auch viel von diesem Hund erzählt, muss man sagen. Also, dass er den mit im Büro hatte, genau. Und dass dieser Hund echt eine große Bedeutung für ihn hatte. Und einfach so im Sinne von diesem – ich habe das schon erwähnt, dass Wolfgang Frank sehr viel auch in seinen Notizen immer das betont hat, dass eben nichts im Leben Zufall ist. Dass diese Gespräche in einer Phase dann stattgefunden haben, in der dieser Hund sehr krank war und das eben gerade eben auch rauskam. Und wir haben uns dann in Frankfurt getroffen und haben eben lange auch über die gemeinsame Zeit gesprochen. Und wirklich wenige Tage nach diesem Gespräch ist dieser Hund gestorben. Und das war eben für sie auch so, dass sie gesagt hat, das war der Punkt, an dem sie es loslassen konnte. Und das war jetzt der Punkt gekommen, an dem sie ihm quasi den Hund schicken konnte. So, also und man kann das manchmal, finde ich, wirklich sehr, sehr schwer begreifen. Also es ist auch so, das ist eine Geschichte, von der ich immer wusste, dass ich die mal erzählen wollen würde, wo ich aber so das Gefühl hatte, sie hat trotzdem im Buch nichts verloren. Aber was wirklich ein ganz, ganz großer Prozess für mich war, bei diesem Buch war, abzuwägen, was erzähle ich und was halte ich privat. Weil es ganz viele Sachen auch gab, die Leute dann durch diese große emotionale Nähe mit ihm erzählt haben, wo für mich total klar war, ich freue mich wahnsinnig über dieses Vertrauen und ich werde diese Geschichten auch immer bei mir tragen. Aber es gibt eben auch Sachen, die gehören nicht ins Buch, weil natürlich möchte ich im Buch nicht nur den Spieler und den Trainer zeigen, sondern auch den Mensch. Aber ich habe ihn ja nie persönlich getroffen und ich habe das immer als ein großes Privileg empfunden, dass Basti und Benni mir das Vertrauen geschenkt haben, das Buch so zu schreiben. Und für mich war immer klar, dass ich auch ein privates Schütze von einem Menschen, also dass ich nicht anfange, irgendwie Sachen auszuschlachten oder Sachen zu erzählen. Letztlich so der Maßstab, was wäre für mich okay, über meinen eigenen Vater zu lesen. Das war eigentlich bei den Privatgeschichten so ein bisschen das, was ich für mich irgendwie genommen habe. Ja, und vielleicht als letztes noch, weil es geht dann jetzt alles, es spielt natürlich am Ende, das Leben ist verbunden mit dem Tod. Und der Tod spielt natürlich im Buch auch dadurch eben eine Rolle, dass Wolfgang Frank leider eben jetzt schon fast zehn Jahre tot ist. Und es sind zwei der Gesprächspartner tatsächlich sogar mittlerweile schon gestorben. Und einer von den beiden ist Sam de Jaga, auf den ich sehr, sehr spät gekommen bin. Es war unfassbar schwierig für die Zeit in Alkmaar eben mit jemandem zu sprechen. Und Sam de Jaga war Journalist und ich habe dann mit ihm sehr, sehr viel gemailt über diese Zeit. Er hat mir total viele spannende Einblicke gegeben. Man muss wirklich sagen, ohne ihn hätte ich dieses Kapitel über Alkmaar nicht schreiben können. Und dann kriegst du plötzlich so nebenbei quasi noch Sachen mit, mit denen du halt überhaupt nicht rechnest. Also weil, wo man eigentlich heute sagen muss, ist es total verwunderlich, dass sein Name nicht viel bekannter ist. Sam de Jaga ist tatsächlich derjenige, der den Begriff totaler Football geprägt hat.
Das dachte ich mir auch, dass es einfach so vorkommt, in deinem Buch, und ich dachte mir so, what?
Eben. Und ein Name, den ich da unbedingt noch erwähnen muss, ist Jan Fisser, der eben tatsächlich mir die ganzen Kontakte für Alkmaar letztlich vermittelt hat und der mir das über den Sam de Jaga auch schon schrieb. Dann dachte ich so, das kann doch irgendwie nicht sein, das müsste doch irgendwie bekannter sein. Und dann habe ich mit ihm eben auch darüber geschrieben, und er hat dann halt so erzählt, ja ja, doch, doch. Er war eben auch sehr kulturinteressiert immer und war da auch viel so im Theaterbereich unterwegs. Und aus dem Theaterbereich wurde das ja quasi übertragen in den Fußball. Also er ist tatsächlich derjenige, der als allererstes diesen Begriff geprägt hat. Und er ist eben auch im Herbst leider verstorben, er ist, muss man sagen, sehr alt geworden. Und es war natürlich trotzdem sehr traurig, von seinem Tod zu hören. Und Jan hat mir dann eben geschrieben, dass bei seiner – ich weiß nicht, ob es bei der Beerdigung oder bei der Trauerfeier war – aber dass das Buch eben auf seinem Sarg lag, weil es das letzte war, woran er mitgearbeitet hat. Ja, und das sind für mich irgendwie so Beispiele dafür einfach, wie sehr die Arbeit an dem Buch und die Beschäftigung mit Wolfgang Frank eben über dieses Rein Sportliche rausgeht. Und da haben wir noch gar nicht angesprochen, die unfassbar vielen Gespräche, die ich eben gerade mit Benni und mit Basti geführt habe, in denen ich so viel mitgenommen habe. Ich habe es am Anfang des Gesprächs gesagt, und das ist für mich auch das, was am Ende steht. Im Endeffekt das, was mir die Arbeit an diesem Buch gegeben hat, das geht wirklich weit über die inhaltliche Recherche und über die inhaltliche Arbeit und über das Sportliche hinaus. Und kann man eigentlich wirklich nur sagen, dass es ein großes Privileg und ein großes Geschenk ist, an so einem Projekt arbeiten zu dürfen. Das wird immer bei mir bleiben.
Ja, das sind tolle Worte. Vielleicht darf ich noch kurz was sagen. Ich meine, ich muss sagen, ich habe das auch toll gefunden, dass du das da auch so respektiert hast, was wir dir dann auch so erzählt haben. Man muss ja auch sagen, auch ein Buch, eine Biografie über jemanden, ist ja nicht das komplette Bild, was man darstellt. Und ich glaube, auch unser Vater war ja kein Heiliger. Also ich glaube, zu ehrlich muss man ja sein. Keiner ist perfekt. Jeder macht Fehler, jeder macht Dinge, die vielleicht dann auch negativ sind. Aber ich weiß nicht, ich finde auch so Bücher müssen ja am Schluss keine Abrechnung sein, sagen, der war gut, der war schlecht, sondern es ist einfach nur ein Bild, das man zeichnet von jemandem, der vielen Leuten was gegeben hat. Und ich finde, dass es am Schluss auch eine positive Message sein soll und nicht jetzt darum geht, jetzt irgendwas zu bewerten. Was hat er richtig, was hat er falsch gemacht? Und ich finde, das ist extrem gut gelungen, das zu transportieren, was er vielen Leuten gegeben hat, wie er war vom Typ her. Und deswegen, wie gesagt, wie ich schon mal zu Beginn, das ist einfach für uns eine Riesengeschichte, da dabei gewesen sein zu dürfen, mit Mara das Buch da zu entwickeln und ihr da unterstützend zur Seite gestanden zu haben. Deswegen nochmal herzlichen Dank auch dafür.
Wir müssen jetzt aufhören, das ist das perfekte Ende. Es war wunderbar, mit euch beiden zu sprechen. Es ist auch wirklich ein ganz, ganz tolles Buch. Das war das, was ich jetzt noch unbedingt sagen wollte. Auch Wolfgang Frank hätte es sicher gerne gelesen, denn man sieht die Arbeit, den Fleiß, die da reingegangen ist. Es ist einfach unglaublich, Mara, was du da geleistet hast. Und ich finde genau das, was du jetzt am Schluss angesprochen hast, ich hätte es nur thematisiert, wenn du es angesprochen hättest. Aber ich finde, dass du diesen Punkt, diese Gradwarnung zwischen öffentlicher Person, privater Person, mit diesen Fragen habe ich mich ja auch sehr beschäftigt, auch selbst schon in meiner eigenen Arbeit. Den hast du perfekt getroffen. Und ich kann wirklich nur allen empfehlen, sorg dafür, dass es eine zweite Auflage gibt. Wolfgang Frank, der Fußballrevolutionär erschienen im Werkstattverlag. Natürlich packe ich den Shownote, den Link in die Shownotes. So ist es richtig, nicht die Shownotes in den Link. Und dann danke ich euch beiden sehr, sehr herzlich. Danke, lieber Sebastian, dass du hier bei deinem ersten und ja vielleicht nicht letzten Rasenfunkauftritt warst. Jetzt darfst du wieder Spieler scouten. Und ich glaube, heute geht es noch nach Belgien. Danke dir für deine Zeit.
Es ist natürlich jetzt für mich auch ein bisschen ein ungewohntes Umfeld da, mich zu äußern. Von daher hoffe ich, das war alles in Ordnung und herzlichen Dank dafür für die Einladung.
Es war ganz wunderbar und ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank, liebe Mara, dass du auch so viel mit uns zu teilen bereit warst. Das weiß ich sehr zu schätzen und vielen Dank für dieses schöne Buch. Wir alle, da nehme ich alle Hörerinnen und Hörer mit rein, weil ich weiß, dass du unglaublich viele Fans hast unter den Hörenden. Wir sind schon sehr gespannt auf dein nächstes Projekt und danke, dass du jetzt hier mit dabei warst.
Ja, vielen, vielen lieben Dank für die Einladung. Es hat großen Spaß gemacht und es wird dich nicht überraschen, wenn ich sage, ich komme auch gerne wieder.
Das ist schön zu hören. Ich brauche dich unbedingt. Wir meinen es nur fünfmal wieder, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Habt noch eine gute Zeit, macht es gut, ihr zwei. Das war unser Gespräch zu Wolfgang Frank. Ich kann euch nur noch mal empfehlen, ich habe es weit schon mehrfach getan, aber das Buch ist wirklich herausragend von Mara. Auch wenn ihr natürlich wisst, dass ich Mara immer sehr gewogen bin, aber macht euch gerne euer eigenes Bild. Ich bin sehr sicher, mein Urteil wird eurem Urteil erstandhalten. Und dann danke ich euch, dass ihr diese Folge gehört habt. Wenn euch generell solche Themen interessieren, dann kann ich euch zum einen das Tribünengespräch mit Norbert Elgert empfehlen. Das werde ich nochmal verlinken. Das war auch ein sehr interessantes Gespräch und es gab erstaunliche Überschneidungen tatsächlich in der Art, wie Norbert Elgert über Fußball denkt, mit Wolfgang Frank. Und dann habe ich in der Vorbereitung auf diese Sendung noch zwei Podcasts gerne gehört. Zum einen den Leader Talk, da habe ich die Folge mit Stefan Leitel mir angehört, und im Kopf des Trainers. Da gab es zwei Folgen mit Sandro Schwarz und vor allem im Kopf des Trainers. Das könnte etwas sein, was vielen von euch gefällt. Ich werde da auch mal versuchen, noch mehr Episoden zu hören. Da lernt man je nachdem, wie breit die Trainer sind, sich zu öffnen. Wirklich einiges und Sandro Schwarz war da, glaube ich, ein Positivbeispiel. Also das möchte ich euch empfehlen. Bis bald, hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund, macht es gut.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück um die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.